when you look at a 3ds you see the a B X
and Y buttons all laid out like a Super
Nintendo controller if that makes you
yearn for some retro classics on your
handheld then I've got good news
starting today you'll be able to
download nest games from the 3ds Virtual
Console as Reggie would say my body is
ready first up are f-zero pilot wings
and super mario world you can download
those three games later today on March
24th you'll be able to grab super mario
kart earthbound and Donkey Kong Country
then on April 14th a Link to the Past
Super Metroid and donkey kong country 2
will be available these versions will
also include a pixel perfect mode which
retains the original resolution of the
snatch game but on the 3ds screen
journeying through Hyrule should look
and feel really good if the nostalgia
bug was biting then this lineup should
be a decent cure Nintendo will announce
Moore's nest titles down the road but
nine games over the next month ain't too
shabby and if you want to stay up to
date on all the virtual console releases
you're ready in the right place